there was a an article I saw
on The Daily Mail and it was like
Mother's a post about how they regret
having kids and what what their lives
were like before kids there's another
post where it was like you know mothers
talk about their regret and what you
know how awful their children are and
I'm just like man they really don't want
you to have they really want to prop up
these narratives about having kids is
bad yep yeah and you can just control
everybody else's kids through the
government school system so do many of
them well in the UK they even had
advertisement being like do you want a
baby or do you want to play video games
as if video games were a good thing
which again a lot of people were finding
you know themselves addicted to and
again I think a lot of this is
multi-faceted I think there is an
element of it that is running away from
personal responsibility I think there's
also an element of it that is
pro-consumer pro multinational
corporation that understands that if
people don't have kids that they don't
have strong family units people will of
course use that energy towards
supporting them rather than themselves
and their family members and I think
deeper down there's also an elitist
level where it's like okay we need to
get rid of the people in this world
there's too many of them we need to do
population control we need to do
Eugenics but we're you know doing it in
many other handed ways that of course is
essentially at the end of the day uh
reducing the the number of people on
this world which already has hit a
critical level where we are going to be
dealing with the civilization crash very
soon all right question are there too
many people we need more we need more
yeah we need more because look in the
future we have all this national debt
we'll have it spread over more people so
it can pay it off in the future if you
have more people you could um have more
resources and that's what we really want
more resources so like the the so so the
the left's thinking of we have too many
people and we have to control population
is the fixed pie fallacy that there's a
finite amount of resources and you
divide it among this many people if you
have more people then that means fewer
resources for each individual person but
that assume rooms that people don't
create these resources themselves and so
I think we don't have enough people yeah
absolutely socialism too like you know
because they want you know more people
the more people in their their fixed
finite whatever like you're not you're
gonna get one bar of soap you that you
get to choose from you know they they
drop stuff like that so that's coming
from kind of their communist or their
socialist you know perspective and then
if you look at uh getting rid of the
family that's that's a tenet of Marxism
like a lot of a lot of these go back to
Marxism it's everywhere and it's not
just Financial ramifications of less
people being around but statistically
the population is increasing but is
expected to go down dramatically if you
look at the Western World people aren't
reproducing enough this is not only
going to lead to a financial crisis but
this is going to lead to a very serious
one which Elon Musk has even compared to
the potential potentially the greatest
risk to humanity is people not
reproducing enough and if you look at
you look at also what's happening behind
the scenes with testosterone levels
sperm levels all of them dramatically
going down there's a big probability
that that human beings could become
infertile very soon with the the rates
of of just estrogen with the rates of
chemical warfare that is happening that
no one really wants to talk about which
is absolutely absurd well certainly
resources are not infinite and more
people doesn't mean more resources it
means less like there's a finite amount
of rare earth minerals that we can
extract from the planet it may be such a
great number we're nowhere near reaching
that cap but the planet is finite in
terms of what its mass is and what we
can extract not to mention that there's
a certain amount of uh I mean we we can
overfish we can we've we've made animals
go extinct before at a certain point I
think that the question is is wrongly
framed when it's are there too many
people it's are we managing the system
properly I think the answer is no I
think it's not being managed properly
and the response from people like Bill
Gates is instead of trying to figure
that out just less people because then
you don't got to worry about it I think
I'm thinking about
aoc's District uh or Nancy Pelosi's
District 770 some odd thousand people
how do you effectively govern that many
people is this thing you can't so the
issue isn't necessarily one of proper
allocation of resources it may be can
you effectively manage this many people
like like together can they work
together in such a way
I I would say right now the systems we
put in place a couple hundred years ago
can't account for this because they were
expecting I think like 35 000 people per
per member of Congress and now we have
nearly a million I mean three quarters
of a million but that that just means we
need to figure out a better way of
managing expectations and and you know
working within the representative system
well you know there's ways of having a
sustainable system there's ways of
individuals being responsible for
themselves having their own Farms
producing their own food there's enough
to go around it nature is an abundant
beautiful landscape that is ready just
to grow food out of the ground and and
what we're seeing from the the central
controllers from the Bill Gates's from
the Klaus Schwabs is move into a city go
eat the bugs and and live in a pot and
again that's not the answer here the
real answer here is people finding
themselves in nature and becoming
dependent on themselves and not
responsible and and not dependent on the
federal government and this is what
another reason why I don't trust any of
their narratives on climate change
overpopulation because they they keep
they they have that video the line the
city where they're gonna put everybody
in a super condensed space and I'm like
population density is supposedly the
problem the pollution the waste but
they're not I don't think they actually
care about climate change I don't think
they actually care about our population
they care about creating a reason to
scare you into living under their
control
Elon Musk is right we need more people I
was watching Star Trek you guys see the
remember the new Star Trek with what's
his name Chris Pine is that his name and
there's that scene where he rides up on
the motorcycle and he sees the gigantic
Starship and I'm just thinking how many
people do you need to build something
like that it's massive we're trying to
build a building right now and it's like
a 7 500 square foot building and it's
taken like a year to get done because of
supply chain crunch imagine trying to
build this massive Starship that has
faster than light travel and can hold
thousands of people or whatever and I
was like you don't just need more people
you need more Specialists so that means
with all the people we have Elon my
point is Elon Musk is right the more
people you have the more Specialties you
can have like some dude can be a
chocolatier I was reading about some guy
I wanted to talk and I'm just like it's
kind of a crazy thing oh no it was the
uh the Bros movie when it was like the
guy wanted to be a chocolatier whatever
was part of the movie in the review and
uh I'm like what a job you know like go
back several hundred years and it's like
you're you're in the middle of the
Wilderness with a hatchet and you're
like I'm gonna stop hunting and go make
chocolate it's not gonna happen no but
as population grows everybody can assume
a very specific job and Specialty so the
more people we have the more
capabilities technologically we have but
I think Bill Gates knows this I think
these powerful Elites know this so their
attitude is we don't necessarily want to
get rid of people we want to get rid of
certain people and have everybody else
live in the cities eat the bugs and do
what we want them to do so we can have
nice things well I think what you hit on
earlier is important too though that it
depends on the system that we operate in
and so if we have more personal
responsibility more of a free market
competition and trade than uh the thing
that I was pointing out earlier that uh
you can get stuck in a fixed pie Pi
fallacy if you don't have those
incentives in place but if you if you do
have a free market and there is
competition there's capitalism you can
have an incentive to produce more even
though there is more people on the
planet you have more resource sources
for per person as opposed to that and I
think it's more than I just want to have
nice things or I want to have it all I
think there's a deeper religious uh
spiritual aspect to this that I think
you know it may be not worth talking
about now but there's a lot of
circumstantial evidence highlighting how
you know human progression has been
created with of course abundant energy
and we see a lot of central controllers
deny energy to populations which of
course denies the progression of
humanity progression of human beings
progression of innovation and technology
that of course creates life a better
life that that is more resilient that is
that is more amazing that is more
incredible they're denying that what if
moloch is real and he wants the blood of
children and you know hey look you know
for all we know Bill Gates is you know
he's down in the Deep dungeon and
there's a there's a big door with big
chains across it needs a lot and there's
a bunch of guys holding the doors like
hold them back I'll bring the children
in brings in a bunch of kids they used
to sacrifice you know children in
ancient civilizations and this is a
practice that of course probably didn't
go away from my own personal opinion and
perspective uh just the way I see the
way Society plays out right now you see
everything going towards one trajectory
and that is destruction of humanity
destruction of the human Spirit and the
will of humanity to progress Build and
Grow you see the government standing in
the way you see the multinational
corporation standing in the way you see
the bankers you see the central
controllers and billionaires standing in
the way of the biggest amazing human
potential that we could unleash on the
world and they're literally trying to
control our thoughts through social
media which is and and limit those
thoughts and limit our energy and limit
our ability to do so which is
infuriating because there's so much
wonders about our existence there's so
many questions there's so much science
there's so much intelligence but all of
that is just being
pooped on by all right
child hurting nasty human beings that
that don't don't don't like the human
spirit and stand against it so there's a
Japanese term it's called ekage and icky
means life and gay means worth and
essentially that's the intersection of
what you're good at uh what you love to
do what gives you what what gives you
purpose and we're at a point where we're
just we're privileged you know I hate
using that word because they've
repurposed it but the fact that we can
we can be chocolatiers yeah you know
like we can we can we can be YouTubers
we can we can be whatever we want to be
um you know and and and the people that
love what they do or the people that add
goodness and Joy to the World and like
we're blessed to be living in a place
where we don't have to you know hack up
trees and you know like grunt to
communicate with each other
um you know so we're in a good place
we're we're in a good place for ikigay
and we gotta we gotta kind of figure out
how to hold that you know on a side note
too I was just thinking when we were
talking about all the people preventing
ikigay essentially
um the banks there was there was one
Banker CEO of somewhere and he was
questioned by Congress on ESG and he was
like absolutely not and it was Rashida
Talib who asked the question and she
didn't even know what yes and she didn't
even know what to do she was just like
oh and she was like all you know
flabbergasted and she was like oh okay
well I guess that you just want climate
change I don't even know like she said
something totally irrational like and
reactionary to him but yeah I was like
okay well you know what this is good
because ESG is to the economy what CRT
is to schools like this is this is bad
so Tim you you had asked about the
population too much for too little the
the temperature on Earth is it too high
or too low
I neither we don't we don't know what
the best answer is right I mean I don't
know yeah I mean nobody knows just
depends on what your preference is I
guess the world goes through normal uh
undulation when it comes to hot and cold
temperatures it goes up it goes down it
goes up it goes down and thanks for
checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the timcast IRL podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there